seth tells this great story in the book
how he gets a call that
tom cruise is now thinking he wants to
do comedy
the real comedy is what happened when
you went to see
tom cruise first of all this is the
movie
i love that you had a pee so bad that
you peed into a snapple bottle
to me with tom cruise i i stopped
halfway up the driveway
kind of in the woods uh above sunset
boulevard
and i peed in a snapple bottle in my car
um
and then i uh sealed the bottle and and
left it there and
went on to have a very absurd meeting
with with tom cruise but
to get to the end of yeah so then as i
was leaving the meeting i was snaking
back
down the driveway and i as i was passing
the exact
spot that i peeded i noticed a red light
in the woods and looked and there was a
security camera
literally pointed exactly where i was
being in this stuff i felt your pain on
that one i
loved it but the meeting was so bizarre
we had been meeting with him for a long
time a few hours we were talking and he
was
and he's and again i said like i'm a
huge tom cruise fan like i [ __ ]
love tom cruise like i see every tom
cruise movie
like i go to theater i can't wait he
that man is determined to die on camera
for our entertainment
and this meeting by the way was at the
time when he was married to katie holmes
and
yes baby with her siri right that was
right when this meeting was was like
it was at the peak of tom cruise like
i mean i used the word mania in a very
literal sense i think in this
in this situation so yeah we met with
him for hours
and not a few hours into the meeting
he goes this scientology stuff comes up
how weird he's looked in the press
lately
kind of how uh yeah just how strange
he's
coming across but he said what you said
in the book was fascinating he said
the press is trying to make me look
crazy because i'm costing the
pharmaceutical industry so much money
because he's against
uh pharmaceuticals and then yeah the
word goes
and it's like with scientology he said
if you
let me just tell you what it was really
about
if you let me just give me like 20
minutes to like really just
tell you what it was about you would say
no
[ __ ] way no [ __ ] way
i remember being like i i remember like
the wording was i was
like is that a good thing to be saying
and i already said like if i if you let
me tell you about jewish people you
would say
no [ __ ] way man no [ __ ] way
and then i remember there was this very
like loaded moment where he says this to
us if you just gave me like 20 minutes
to tell you about this you would say no
[ __ ] way you'd be in general looking
at each other and i'm like is he gonna
bite am i gonna bite are we
how can we come out of this are we
strong enough
to have him do this to us and not
be converted i don't know if i am i
i i'm a weak i generally a weak willed
weak-minded person i would assume
on the grand scale of people like if
they got him
how what chance do i have you know um
and thank god judd was like i think
we're good like let's just talk about
movies and stuff like that
right dodge that bullet